hohe mieten ohne mieten decke kostet
eine wohnung zb 350 euro und dann wenn
der mieten deckel weg fällt auf einmal
900 euro und das ist kein scherz zu
wenig wohnraum was ich da gesehen habe
war dass sich auf eine wohnung hunderte
von leuten beworben haben und auch zu
besichtigungsterminen die trotz time
slots extrem überlaufen waren also
schlangen die sich über blöcke hinweg
gezogen haben 1,5 millionen wohnungen
fehlen etwa zwei jahre in stuttgart nach
9 uhr gesucht weil wir wegen
familienzuwachs eine wohnung mit netze
man behaupten
fehlende instandhaltung wir haben fälle
wo die alte oma bei deutsche wohnen im
siebten stock sitzt im rollstuhl sitzt
oder fällt der fahrstuhl für woche aus
dann ist die darauf angewiesen dass ihre
nachbarn in lebensmittel bringen solche
fälle gibt es jeden tag in wellen auf
dem wohnungsmarkt gibt so einige
probleme ihr habt bestimmt schon öfter
gehört und vielleicht auch selbst schon
erlebt in berlin wurde im vergangenen
jahr versucht mit einem mieten decke
gegen die steigenden mieten anzusteuern
der wurde aber im apres gekippt und
jetzt steigen die mieten in berlin
wieder so wie in vielen anderen städten
deutschlands
bisher hat das also nicht möglich was
gebracht ich frage mich sind radikale
ideen notwendig sowie die einer
initiative wohnungsgesellschaften die
die deutsche wohnen und weiten aber geht
das überhaupt und was würde es bringen
das will ich herausfinden
bevor wir uns die mögliche lösung
anschauen kurz noch mal einen blick auf
das problem hier für den überblick noch
mal die fakten
erstens die steigenden mieten die zehn
kreis städte mit den höchsten mieten pro
quadratmeter sind diese hier
das sind städte mit vielen einwohnern
sowie münchen frankfurt am main oder
berlin aber auch deutlich kleinere
städte wie mainz oder darmstadt und die
hohen betreffen so gut wie alle
großstädte in deutschland eine analyse
des immobilienportals immowelt.de von
anfang 2020 zeigt dass in den
vergangenen zehn jahren dienten
überproportional gestiegen sind
ganz konkret die inflation lag bei 14
man hat sich 80 großstädte angeschaut
und bei 77 lag die mietsteigerung über
der inflation um noch genauer zu sein
bei dem 77 stellen lag im durchschnitt
die steigerung bei 36 prozent
das krasseste beispiel berlin da haben
sich minuten mehr als verdoppelt das
liegt auch daran dass der zuzug in die
städte sehr groß ist und wohnraum fehlt
das treibt die mietpreise in die höhe
laut dem deutschen mieterbund fühlen in
deutschland 1 5 millionen wohnen vor
allem bezahlbare und sozialwohnungen
seit 2006 hat sich die zahl der
sozialwohnungen fast halbiert obwohl wir
diese wohnung natürlich brauchen
wohnungsgesellschaften wie zum beispiel
die deutsche wohnen oder wohnungen wir
haben mehrere hunderttausend wohnungen
in deutschland und sie sind
börsennotiert das bedeutet dass sie
jährlich eine dividende an die aktionäre
auszahlen
damit werden die waren behandelt aber
wieso ist das alles so um das zu
verstehen schauen wir ins jahr 1990 bis
dahin gab es das wohnungs
gemeinnützigkeit gesetz das hat sicher
gestellt dass kommunen wohnung zu
günstigen preisen anbieten konnten
1990 wurde das gesetz gekippt und danach
wurden die gemeinnützigen wohnungen nach
und nach verkauft weil die zum geld
brauchten auch an die deutsche wohnen
2003 kam dann das investment
modernisierungsgesetz damit konnten
große immobilienfonds und
investmentgesellschaften immobilien in
deutschland auf kaufen und die sind in
der regel an renditen interessiert und
somit wurden
immer mehr zu wahren und jetzt gibt es
eine idee die das in berlin quasi
rückgängig machen möchte die deutschen
wohnen info enteignen so heißt die
initiative also bestimmte berliner
wohnungen sollen wieder zurück in
kommunaler hand
es geht darum die größten
immobilienkonzerne im ersten moment
dachte ich hätte geht das überhaupt das
klingt ein bisschen nach sozialismus
aber die idee basiert auf einem artikel
des grundgesetzes grund und boden können
zum zwecke der vergesellschaftung durch
ein gesetz das art und ausmaß der
entschädigung regelt in gemeineigentum
oder andere formen der gemeinwirtschaft
überführt werden
aber bisher wurde von diesem artikel
noch kein gebrauch gemacht deshalb
wollte ich noch mal bei einem juristen
nachhaken ist das denn wirklich
unmöglich
das ist möglich man muss allerdings
sagen dass artikel 5 grundgesetz der hat
bisher noch keine anwendung gefunden
seitdem das grundgesetz besteht also das
ist ein absolutes no go was ihr
gefordert ist und weiß auch vieles
ungeklärt plastik kann man sich das so
vorstellen dass man zumindest mein
eindruck bekommen hat war mir schon die
andere richtung gemacht die
privatisierung beispielsweise die
deutsche bundesbahn im privatisiert
worden ist und die aktiven
gesellschaften auch sozialisierung
genannt ist im prinzip der andere weg
zurück zu sagen also rein juristisch ist
es möglich noch mal konkret die
initiative fordert wenn
immobilienkonzerne mehr als 3000
wohnungen in berlin haben sollen diese
wohnung vergesellschaftet werden
das bedeutet sie gehen in kommunalen
besitz über insgesamt wären das mehr als
240.000 forderungen man erhofft sich
dadurch unter anderem dass die mieten
dauerhaft bezahlbar bleiben für dieses
volksbegehren sammelt die initiative
unterschriften
denn es bis zum 26 juni mehr als 175.000
sind wird am 26 september in einem
volksentscheid darüber abgestimmt
das alles ist ein ziemlich radikaler
schritt aber für die aktivisten der
initiative gibt es keinen anderen ausweg
alle anderen maßnahmen
nichts gefruchtet ganz im gegenteil die
berlinerin der berliner in der breite
haben angst vor der zukunft und angst
was aus ihren wohnungen wird und noch
eine info zur aktuellen entwicklung es
könnte eine mega fusion geben
die beiden größten deutschen
immobilienkonzerne wo novia und deutsche
wohnen wollen sich zusammenschließen
in berlin kommen dann die meisten
wohnungen im neuen konzern von der
deutschen wohnen um den mietern eine
sicherheit zu bieten haben die beiden
immobilien unternehmens vorgeschlagen
preissteigerungen in den kommenden drei
jahren zu begrenzen und 20.000 wohnungen
an die stadt berlin zu verkaufen das auf
dem wohnungsmarkt etwas passieren muss
da sind sich fast alle einig ob die
vergesellschaftung eine lösung für die
situation in berlin ist darüber habe ich
mit kritikern und befürwortern
gesprochen
mit julia schramm von der linken mit
daniel fürst von der fdp mit michael
prütz von der initiative und mit
maximilian fuhrmann vom deutschen
gewerkschaftsbund die
wohnungsgesellschaft deutsche wohnen
wollte nicht mit mir sprechen
das erste thema bei dem sich die zwei
lager nicht einig sind ist das thema
geld wir erinnern uns im grundgesetz
heißt es bei einer vergesellschaftung
muss eine entschädigung gezahlt werden
weiter heißt es die entschädigung ist
unter gerechter abwägung der interessen
der allgemeinheit und der beteiligten zu
bestimmen so das ist ziemlich vage sind
im moment gegen die kritiker und
initiative von verschiedenen zahlen aus
die kritiker rechnen mit einer
entschädigung in höhe von circa 36
milliarden euro
das sei der marktwert der wohnung die
initiative rechnet mit ca 13,7
milliarden euro orientiert an einer
fairen miete für armutsgefährdete
haushalte wie würde man das denn
finanzieren
also wir haben jetzt heute den vorschlag
unterbreitet dass die entschädigung über
40 jahren gesteckt gestreckt wird der
wohnungsbaukonzern bekommen sonst sagen
schuldverschreibungen ja also fonds
ausgezahlt und sukzessive und die
entschädigung die vereinbart waren über
40 jahren aus dem laufenden mieten
bezahlt damit neun toren bester berlin
der haushalte nicht berührt werden muss
ob das so klappt ist noch nicht klar
aber die gegenseite denkt dass das geld
woanders besser investiert wäre gibt
hunderte von millionen von euro
teilweise 42 milliarden aus hat aber
keine einzige wohnung mehr und das ist
ein problem ist da sagen wir dann soll
der staat lieber das geld nehmen soll
selber bauen
meinetwegen auch belegt rechte kaufen
weil sie zum vermieter gehen und sagen
ich kaufte jedes recht ab den mieter
auszusuchen werden
und damit sind wir beim shop argument
das für die kritiker entgegen die
vergesellschaftung spricht die
vergesellschaftung baut verloren wohnung
und uns wieder hinter den wohnungsbau
nicht heute schon gar nicht das
hauptproblem am wohnungsmarkt sind die
fehlenden wohnungen vor allem die
bezahlbare wohnung das problem löst die
vergesellschaftung nicht und das sind
ihre texte selbst aus berlin hat zu
wenig ohne wir haben zudem zog es ist
klar da muss was passieren das ist steht
völlig außer frage das heißt man müsste
jetzt mal mehr bauen schneller und
günstiger bauen und dafür endlich den
raum nicht ausbluten lassen was noch
passiert und dann wird mir die
wohnkosten krise gekommen die frage ist
doch was wird gebaut wenn wir überall
luxuswohnungen bauen und dann niemand
drin wohnen kann weil der quadratmeter
25 euro eintritt kostet ist nichts
gewonnen
das wohnung gebaut werden müssen steht
außer frage
kritiker befürchten aber dass die
vergesellschaftung genau das blockiert
somit der gesellschaft umtreibt dann
schon auch die investoren aus dem markt
weil sie einfach angst haben
ok ich baue da jetzt im haus meiner
ringer mit 30% sozialwohnungen und
wohnungsbau keiner kann mir garantieren
dass es behalten darf die initiative
findet aber dass das genau das richtige
signal an die investoren wäre
wir wollen internationale spekulanten
vertreiben aus dieser stadt ganz
eindeutig und klar gesagt wir wollen
diese leute nicht
ja aber wenn jemand ehrlichen herzens
kommt und sagt ich brauche ich ein paar
neue wohnungen hin da muss die stadt
offen ist bauland verderben ich bei euch
ein paar vernünftige wohnungen für 68
euro den quadratmeter im neubau dann ist
er herzlich willkommen und muss sich um
gar nicht so gemacht
und an sich ist natürlich dass das ziel
der kampagne mehr wohnungen wieder in
den öffentlichen stand zu bringen
die fehler hat jetzt 2000er jahre der
privatisierung die fehler
zurückzuschrauben
dann auch erst mal was ich für
begrüßenswert halte weil wenn in der
öffentlichen hand sind ist eine
demokratische kontrolle darüber
zumindest in teilen wenn sie an der
börse gar nicht werden nicht und ich
erhoffe mir dass klar wird das wohnen
ein menschenrecht ist und dass jeder
mensch das recht hat ein dach über dem
kopf zu haben und dass klar wird dass es
wohnen ebenso wie nahrungsmitteln nicht
spekulationsobjekt sein dürfen also
einige sehen die immobilienkonzerne in
der verantwortung für die hohen
steigenden mieten in berlin und wollen
sich durch die vergesellschaftung
mitspracherecht zurückholen und
dauerhaft bezahlbare guten schaffen
andere sehen dadurch das problem nicht
gelöst sind er glaube man könnte einfach
so sackten in deutschland enteignen und
das kostet gar nicht so man hat es dann
das stimmt ja nicht
aber jetzt muss man auch sagen was man
die wohnung und trotzdem baut die vielen
und da war es viel wichtiger dass sich
zu konzentrieren dass man können sie da
war wenn man günstiger baut man kann
auch günstiger wohnen
durch die initiative steigt zumindest
der druck auf die größten
immobilienkonzerne und das könnte etwas
bewirken
und falls es wirklich zur
vergesellschaftung kommt dann könnten
den minuten in einem bestimmten segment
zumindest bezahlbar bleiben könnt ihr
das den menschen in berlin eine erste
atempause geben ja vielleicht aber ich
frage mich was denn passieren muss damit
dem problem der steigenden nur
grundsätzlich und auch deutschlandweit
entgegengewirkt werden kann
ich glaube der staat muss halt an vielen
punkten als investor irgendwie
vorangehen
weil es anders nicht klappt was denkt
ihr
welche rolle sollte der staat spielen
könnte die vergesellschaftung im spiel
der hohen mieten etwas bringen oder ist
sie gar keine lösung für das problem
schreibt uns eure gedanken in die
kommentare
[Musik]